so so folks i want you to hear this uh
story
of this man who just did an interview
he's a former
um
i want to say a political prisoner in
china and during the interview she tell
he tells the interviewer that u.s is an
authoritative this story is is this on
what what cernovich okay it's on
cernovich's account
let me see if i can pull this off
um
oh you just go to twitter right there no
[ __ ]
if you don't have it i'll try to get it
from here
i'll go to his media
here we go all right you're describing
the directives
during the culture just plus the video
yeah that would be distributed publicly
every night
and then you write this is your quote
they served
a function similar to donald trump's
late night tweets while in office
they were the direct communication of a
leader's thoughts to his devoted
followers enhancing the sanctity of his
authority
so do you see donald trump as an
authoritarian
i
well i don't you know he if you are
authoritarian you have to have a system
where he's supporting you crazy you
cannot just be an authoritarian by
yourself
but certainly
in united states with today's
condition
you can easily have authoritarian
in many ways you're already
in the authoritarian state you just
don't know it
how so
many things happens today in u.s is can
be compared cultural revolution in china
like what
like people trying to be
unified in certain political correctness
that is very dangerous
interesting how he says trump is not an
authoritative because you need a
supportive
system like meeting the media to support
you what you have to say other political
people maybe you can go out there and do
what she is doing do you agree with his
sentiment the fact that u.s is an
authoritative state
i think we're on the cusp of it i think
we see a lot of things going on vaccine
mandates and other things i think in
many ways we're on the cusp and daniella
daniel what do you think
i think that this entire post-pandemic
era has
made a lot of people who were talking
about the 7.8 million
gap that's not in the labor force
anymore i think that this whole
experience has made a lot of american
sheep
to where they're not thinking for
themselves
and that in in those types of
environments it's very easy for an
authoritarian state to come in and move
in
because people have been thought to not
think for themselves
and if people aren't thinking for
themselves then by definition
you're on a very slippery slope to being
able to control their thinking control
their actions yeah let me think let me
think um come first i think you call it
brainwashing brainwashing phrases coming
to mind decades ago useful idiots do do
you do you know what trump just said
trump just said earlier today he says
hospitalizations rising among fully
vaccinated in the u.s would you agree
with them
saying that he's saying hospitalization
rising amongst fully vaccinated in the
us
do you think he's just saying that
because it's a marketing thing or not
actually i think there's statistics what
do you think
hey i'm gonna jump in here i was sitting
by a doctor uh in in in the plane
yesterday i don't normally talk to
people on planes but there i was talking
to this doctor and
he has seen a rise in breakthrough cases
yeah but they're in and out in a few
days okay so you want to pull that up on
who really said that because it wasn't
trump that said that you know who said
that here's who said that yesterday his
name is
dr
anthony fauci is who said
hospitalization is increasing for people
who have
taken the vaccine okay yeah because now
we're on now we're on the booster thing
right no not that one this was november
17th so whatever november 17th it's the
one i texted you but it says right there
three days ago cnbc
no no it's the one from yesterday okay
there you go 16 hours ago
hospitalization rising amongst fully
vaccine
in the u.s fauci says what we're
starting to see now is an uptick in
hospitalization amongst people who've
been vaccinated but not boosted so what
is this now now this next phase is got
to get you boosted see i know you got
the vaccine but we got to get you
boosted and another one and another one
as casey
19 rise uh throughout the u.s health
officials warned that an increasing
number of holidays vaccinated people are
being hospitalized or going into
emergency rooms they're concerned about
the
wanting immunity against the covet
infection comes that the from the fda is
expected to authori authorize a pfizer
bio and tech vaccine booster shot for
all adults 18 and older what we're
starting to see now is an uptick in
hospitalizations amongst people who are
fully vaccinated but not boosted
and it's a significant proportion but
not the majority in uh by any means so
look
the part that i think frustrates people
the most um
is
gaslighting at the highest level
propagandas at the highest level force
at the highest level we used to be able
to choose
today you are forced to do things you
don't want to do uh you know you sit
with somebody and somebody tells you
makes a case on why you ought to get
vaccinated you go get vaccinated
somebody makes the case to you why maybe
you don't need to get vaccinated you get
canceled you know it's
people are starting to get a little
worried about whether they can speak up
or not now
so this guy when he's talking about
authoritative and what to do
the only side that can probably pull off
an authoritative type of an environment
is not the right
and the reason why i say this let me
explain why i said so when you hear
rogan talk about i think rogan was with
who yesterday or two days ago was
himself alex jones uh tyler who were
they with were they with uh tim cast or
i don't know who they were they there
was somebody's podcast two days ago were
you aware of who was or you weren't
following yeah
and you know he was making a point the
fact that you just can't have an
opposing idea today when you can't have
an opposing idea but on one side
whatever you say the media is going to
come and back you up and you can't get
cancelled that's a form of authoritative
the media mainstream media essentially
becomes the authoritative's tool
to say whatever they want to say and get
away with it voucher foresees full
vaccination including booster shots this
is september 3rd yeah we're seeing that
all over the place anyways there's a
reason why people are concerned today
and this guy's making a point do you
agree with what he had to say
about booster shots or you know about
authoritative look about the the chinese
guys so look i don't think so and i'll
tell you why every
there's something that we've come to
find out in america is something called
the pendulum effect every four to eight
years the country swings a little bit to
the left or it swings a little bit to
the right the reason that we went from
george w bush to the right to obama
eight years later obama to trump is
because they thought that he went too
far left the reason that we went to
trump until biden is we thought that
trump went too far right so the reason
that i think the democrats are going to
get shellacked
in the midterms is because they think
that the country under biden under a
house and under a split senate where
kamala has the deciding vote that the
country is going too far left as
danielle so poignantly explained in her
beautiful bar graph that was an amazing
bar graph so
the
the
our country figures it out every four to
eight years the author like the
hyperbolic talk doesn't get us anywhere
follow the facts you're a numbers guy
every four to eight years the country
says hmm
i don't like the way the direction we're
going with trump let's give biden a shot
biden's kind of falling asleep with the
wheel
let's give someone else a shot ah
it's the same old story that we've come
to learn all right all right
let's
answer here's where you say i agree with
you adam go ahead because that's going
to happen
answer this question
answer this question
has
as the pendulum has swung back and forth
as you so eloquently describe
has wealth inequality in this country
gotten wider or gotten narrower wealth
has uh wealth inequality has gotten
wider you're correct okay so that that's
that's going on in the background does
wealth inequality create the the
situation
for social unrest
it always does okay so it's continued to
build in the background regardless of
where your pendulum is
yes that's problematic
what's your point
when people are desperate yeah
and increasing numbers of americans are
desperate like they would be in a third
world there's no developed country in
the world that has a wealth inequality
like we do
you've got to go to like pakistan i mean
there's no developed country in the
world
so if if people are desperate they'll do
something and it doesn't matter what
side they're on or not
the wealth inequality in and of itself
makes the country vulnerable to becoming
authoritarian
people will be willing to listen to
somebody who says rise up against the
elite why do you think donald trump won
because he was going to drain the swamp
and why do you think that resonated with
so many hard-working americans because
they feel like they've been left behind
and why do you think he did not get
elected the second time around is
because he got a swamp he was the
biggest swamp monster of them all right
so he he didn't drain the swamp dude but
he hit a nerve
nerve is still that nervous
that nerve is still raw no it's called
covic nothing's been if any if anything
the nerve is even raw because the really
hard-working americans who tend it to be
part of trump's base are really pissed
off now that there's been this attempt
at socialism in america and they've had
they've had and they have to wait longer
at a restaurant than they've ever had to
wait they have to pay more for a gallon
of gas so the vestiges of socialism have
left
a ton of america just 70 million or so
it's left their nerves even
more raw than they were before that's
problematic they're vulnerable they're
vulnerable to being led right into an
authoritarian trap i'll give you a great
quote give a great quote rise up against
the unrest i'll make the trains run on
time we'll start there who said that
mussolini correct why because things
were so bad that the people were willing
to go along with that and they walked
right into the authoritarians i haven't
i haven't they're basically saying that
mussolini we're right for a mussolini
here i have a question for you
is it ironic that trump always gets
compared to mussolini
i didn't compare trump to mussolini i'm
pointing out that what she just said is
absolutely correct when there's unrest
and there's people that have these these
stifled frustrations and it's
broad-based
they are ripe to follow the wrong guy
now who do you think is frustrated
hold on
hello we were just talking about wealth
and inequality you're paying attention
you're saying that it's immune it's only
on the right i'm saying people who are
working hard and seeing the colorful
charts paid to not work are really
pissing off the hard workers i have a
question thank you we've got military
background here sitting across me right
yeah spam
what happens to countries
when states
eventually fail to lead i'm talking
about entire states what what happens to
a country what happens we talk about
individual states like texas or nations
nations what happens to nations where
the politicians fail
who rises people
no
what what type of leaders rise
tell me the generals
the military okay
that's where this country could be
headed you're saying like militia like
you're saying military ruling the
country
if we keep having
remember we talked about it an hour and
a half ago the republicans and the
democrats are both whenever they're in
in office whenever they're both in
leadership
spending like drunken sailors we've
talked about this so what happens one
day when and if possibly americans feel
like they're not represented at all
i mean right now i've never seen an
administration as vulnerable as the
biden administration is today because
again they're paralyzed they can't do
anything
but the people who run our military
they're they're doers
they're not sayers
and so if so is that a concern of yours
are you excited about that
i think that would be fairly concerning
for the united states tell me why to be
a military state what happens what would
it be like brazil 1981 i mean okay so
why why why do you think that would even
happen here though
because americans are losing faith in
the the reason that independent voters
are growing as a proportion of the
electorate is because there's a an
increasing proportion who feel like
they're not represented by anybody
at all
you make yourself vulnerable to becoming
an authoritarian state which is what
started this whole discussion
but what do authoritarian states look
like
the leaders tend to be militaristic
dictators
types
not wishy-washy joe biden
who can't get anything done that's how
chavez got power in venezuela that's
exactly that's exactly how chavez wrote
i lived in venezuela and i saw it right
before and that's exactly how hugo
chavez rose to power i'll make the train
track are you basically saying that a
general is going to run for the
president i'm saying and when are you
saying that they're the military
take over thank you that's authoritarian
i'm saying that now do you actually
believe that or are you just giving away
we don't legislate for the people you
mentioned three things right the deficit
needs to come down
right interest rates need to come up
right
what was your third and the third is
money supply you got to control the
money supply okay all these things are
are we going in in the right direction
on any of okay money supply is coming
down because we we can't legislate until
after the midterms when then the
republicans are going to start spending
money on when you say why has had a
temporary moderation if you extend that
back 18 months it's grown grown grown so
we are
redlining with certain moments of
moderation we're redlining the growth of
the money supply has come way off you
have to wait until after the the
midterms and then the republicans will
spend on what they want daniel i'm
agreeing it's come off it's moderated in
the most recent i'm just i'm asking
somebody who served in the military
you pay attention to your leaders if
they're strong leaders if our country
can't find any strong leaders they're
going to pay attention to the people who
are strong and running our military i'm
just talking about the possible end game
you brought you you brought up the word
patrick authoritarian you played the
you you played the video
the guy from china says that we're
vulnerable yeah but he's the the point
he made that stuck with me
is the reason why trump couldn't be an
authoritative guy is because you need
the system to support it right right so
let's what what i wish you would have
asked the question i would ask them tell
me what's the system what what is the
system is the media part of the system
is it educational system it's part of
the system
i want to know about that
okay
and then what i'm saying to you is
that'll never happen on the right here's
why let me explain so yesterday we're
having this conversation together
yesterday
we agree on that okay so let me explain
to you why here's how this works so
here's how this works you know how uh uh
two kids are playing and they're using
the toys okay they got their favorite
toys sitting there and they they like a
lot of the same toys so adam says adam
you go first pick your first toy so
knowing adam he takes a little doll the
cat doll whatever he takes that doll i
said okay that's right
then it's my turn i take that little car
whatever the car is then he takes his
own and then we're going to go right
okay so the left and the right are
sitting in a room together right across
from each other they're gonna say okay
left you go first okay
left goes first you know what um
we're gonna take the educational system
and we're gonna influence that [ __ ]
that's big okay we'll take the church
okay cool the most the church is
conservative fine what are you gonna
take next
we're gonna take mainstream media damn i
should have taken that first damn that's
powerful okay uh we'll take the military
okay cool you got military okay we we're
gonna take you know uh virtual
government social media all in silicon
valley and they're to be on the left
we're going to control that
freaking hey i should have thought of
that ah let me see what i'm okay we'll
take a lot of the crypto community
because a lot of the crypto communities
are libertarian so it's center right but
it's on the right fine we'll take crypto
yeah we'll give you that it's only seven
percent it's not a big deal they're
going back and forth back and forth back
and forth now you look at the left what
they got
they're stacked with things that they
got stacked union left stacked with what
things they got there so now the right
is in there saying we kind of screwed up
what are we going to do now okay so in
this instance the reason why i say the
right cannot be authoritative is because
the system doesn't back up the right the
only person that can be authoritative is
somebody from the left because they have
a majority of the system and if somebody
strategically from their left truly
wants to be authoritative in america
what do you got to do here's what you
got to do strategically
you got to make people's people first
thing you got to do is change the tax
code for churches that's what you got to
do so if a pastor from stage says
something that is out of line you got to
remove their tax code you can no longer
take money and that becomes okay if
you're going to go that direction that's
how you got to do them number two the
system on how military is being
indoctrinated you need more people like
millie who at crt who had all this other
stuff and soften up the military that's
the strategic move you got to do that's
what you got to do number three what do
you do with crypto what you do with
crypto is regulate the [ __ ] out of it so
making those people disappear because
they're still not starting to becoming a
pain in the ass because some of these
guys actually have money we don't like
libertarians being rich because they
already don't give a [ __ ] and they want
to be left alone and now they're the
type of people that are going to say
screw you you can't tell me what to do
because i'm a damn libertarian and these
crypto people are libertarian
if the left wants to truly be an
authoritative state those three
organizations you got to go take out now
if the right wants to create that
freedom for everybody to choose you got
to kind of start producing some
universities you got to kind of start
educating people you got to kind of
start talking about how great capitalism
is you got to start selling the dream
you got to be attractive you got to get
that younger audience you got to get the
people that are telling the story the
right way and then some people are going
to sit there and say you know what this
kind of started to make sense to me so i
i i mean who on the left is coming out
and saying
teachers unions destroyed jobs teachers
unions destroyed families teachers
unions prevented mothers from being able
to rejoin the workforce who's going to
come out and say that
yeah of course they're not going to say
that and to me the other day i made a
comment about teachers people flipped
out
i said look there's about 40 percent of
teachers should be fired because they
flat out suck
there's a lot of they're not accountable
not only are they not accountable they
don't like their jobs they don't care
listen let me tell you let me they don't
like kids let me put it to you this way
if i ever was a front desk clerk you
should fire me because i'm probably not
going to be a good front desk clerk if i
wasn't from this club
if you're a bit adhd yeah i'm not going
to be a good front desk clerk right if i
was a waiter you should fire me because
i'd probably be asking you to learn a
lot more about you and i'm gonna forget
the fact that you wanted drinks and your
burger is gonna come with onions even
though you said no onions i'm gonna
forget about it on the way back and
you're gonna be like freaking how many
times do you remember the onion thing
yeah yeah that's not a matter of fact if
you got that extreme ask for
the point is there's a lot of bad
teachers out there that should get fired
completely not be teaching today but
that's what we learned during covet so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]